اظهر مقطع فيديو قيام جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالاعتداء بشكل وحشي على احد
عمال محطه وقود عند مدخل مخيم الفوار جنوب
الخليل وظهر في الفيديو احد الجنود وهو
يركل بقدمه الشاب بعد ان طرحه ارضا بينما
ظهر جندي اخر وهو يدوس على الشاب قبل ان
ينسحب الجنود من
المحطه
معنا مند الخليل مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار
منتصر مرحبا
بك لو نبدا من هذا الخبر وهذه الحادثه
الاخيره الفيديو الذي يظهر قيام جنود
الاحتلال بهذا الاعتداء على احد عمال محطه
وقود كان ذلك عند مدخل مخيم الفوار اي
جنوب الخليل هل من تفاصيل حول هذه الحادثه
وايضا السلوك الاسرائيلي في الاقتحامات في
الخليل
تحديدا
نعم محمد يعني نحن نقف مقابل هذه المحطه
تماما عند مدخل مخيم الفوار جنوب الخليل
هذا اليوم الاعتداءات لم تقتصر فقط على
هذا الشاب الذي ظهر من خلال فيديو خاص
بكاميرات المراقبه الموجوده داخل هذه
المحطه كيف يعتدي جنود الاحتلال بشكل
مباشر على هذا العامل بعد ان قاموا بركله
وطرحه ارضا ثم قام احد الجنود دوس عليه
قبل ان ينسحبوا من المكان وكانوا جنود
الاحتلال اعطوا اشارات ايضا الى كاميرات
المراقبه ذلك يعني انهم يعرفون ان هناك
كاميرات مراقبه توثق ما يجر ومع ذلك
هم لا يلقون بالا او خاطرا لذلك وبالتالي
اعتداءات الجنود مستمره ومتواصله هذا
السلوك حدث في هذه المحطه عند مدخل مخيم
الفوار الذي يظهر ايضا من خلال هذه الصوره
محمد هذا اليوم بالتحديد قوات الاحتلال
تنكل في المواطنين بمخيم الفوار قبل قليل
كنا نستمع لجنود الاحتلال وهم يوجهون
نداءات او في هذه اللحظات الان يوجهون
نداءات عبر مكبرات الصوت للمواطنين
ويعتدون عليهم الذي يظهر امامنا مباشره في
هذه الصوره هو مدخل مخيم الفوار المغلق
ببوابه حديديه منذ السابع من اكتوبر في
الاونه الاخيره الاحتلال اقتحم مخيم
الفوار اكثر من مره كان اخرها الليله
الماضيه ونكل بعائله الشهيد عمار ابو حسين
وبعدد من المنازل في مخيم الفوار تفاجا
المواطنون هذا الصباح بان قوات الاحتلال
تمنعهم حتى ان يسيروا بالاقدام يعني منذ
السابع من اكتوبر البوابات مغلقه ويسمح
للمواطنين بالسير على الاقدام لكن اليوم
منعوا من السير على الاقدام في هذا المكان
وبالتالي هذا شكل جديد من اشكال التنكيل
بحق المواطنين محمد شكرا جزيلا لك منتصر
نصار مراسل الجزيره من
الخليل